my name is chris olsen my website see k
open a comm my twitter handle is ck
olsen presents Harold the whole of the
game
I love making people laugh I love
animation I do a lot of live-action work
really
really thats will get back in and to do
something
for the four kids for the family film so
it was a nice realization of storing the
second
and for your mentors are you
modeling yourself after
the world would be a much worse place at
Disney head and come in I always call
Walt Disney World
the mothership of creation but I just
love how he created a place it really
anyone can go anyone can live like what
we try again
making the short film what challenges
did you face I mean was it all glamour
and fun and making for you or were there
times when you wanted to give up the key
but the animation is it's a lot of
laborious work even when you're doing
live-action film making that the
technology cause its own out the editing
constant come down but if you're just
doing drawing there's no way to make a
drawing process faster so it's good you
just have to sit down to draw this it
required a lovely talented ambulance
work of this project button the drawings
for so fun it was so funny give me this
about a year and a half to get done but
how are you spreading the word about the
project we're doing everyone's creating
about it through social media but a lot
of this is grassroots ela we we had our
premiere this art our second festival we
got two more on the road coming up with
the person was a middle rock and the
first thing we do is make sure we got in
front of 300 kids and their parents and
so we have a great for near there
because that's our audience we want
people to see this winter kids who want
people to enjoy it and it just goes
great hearing those gut busting last the
entire time and lastly which one
takeaway sort of a epiphany that you had
you were surprised whether it's good or
bad if you have experience
as soon as I finish this bill I knew I
wish I could gone back yet and it worked
on a couple see Natalie ride every time
I go into a frog Rebecca's you learn
along the way by the end of it before
that we start so we could take your next
one and then apply that knowledge okay
it's really everything I've done this
one included I made you better filmmaker
in the next round